black queen is distracted knight f6 is  the idea and uh trying to get some  because perpetua  yeah exactly that's why i i was thinking  by i don't know this kind of stuff was  still super complicated super  complicated black king goes into the  yeah  yeah maybe you can take this one uh with  your rook and checkmate is coming and  we have these big things going on yeah  massive things okay we have to go back  to the players now because we're about  to see a draw we will explain this later  and uh we are about to see a draw by  perpetual check  massive drama magnus uh was a bit about  to take under the minute the bar going  back and forth he only needs a draw  and it is going to be a draw nothing  else to do and magnus clinches it what a  game and did we see a handshake but it  is a match loss for lavon aronian losing  one game to magnus carlson magnus  clinches all three points  nine out of nine possible points so far  in the fdx crypto cup four